I would think if you have a
two-and-a-half-year-old you're probably
doing fun things with her her is that
right lots of games lots of songs and
stuff I built a we'd be getting too much
cardboard from all of our deliveries so
I repurposed some cardboard into a train
that I made a train
I made a cardboard train for my daughter
Wow how now is this just like okay I'll
put one box in front of another and
that's the engine and this is the
caboose with it and I'm knowing you I'm
guessing it got a little more elaborate
yeah so I'm kind of crafty a little bit
of a craft nerd and I got I got two into
it I'm just gonna admit it my wife kept
saying exactly what you just said she
would be fine with two boxes next to
each other and I was like yeah but that
that's I'm not okay with that and so I
put a lot of hours and it became clearly
my own sort of coping mechanism as much
as something for my daughter
so wait I mean how detailed is this
thing first of all how big is it well
it's a fully working coal powered
locomotive a coal powered cardboard in
engine that's that's problematic and
have you fired it up yet no I'm scared
too honestly but I know it'll work if I
do at least for a couple of seconds but
no it's it's fairly big you know it's a
child's train that she can get inside of
and pretend like she's a choo-choo
engineer you know what's gonna happen
it starts that way I once built a train
for my son and he started out going
choo-choo and then within months he went
on strike
commanded he demanded different hours he
invoked all kind of federal acts
la kicked and he tied me up in the
courts the train never ran on time it
lost money so I'm just telling you this
is what's coming as your child gets
older